In the inaugural season of Netflix's The Witcher,
the Law of Surprise is the hinge upon which
the entire plot twists but for those coming
to the series having no familiarity with the
property, it may seem a bit confusing.
What does the Law of Surprise mean to Geralt
and his world?
The concept has taken many forms across a
lot of cultures' folklore, but it basically
boils down to this: in exchange for an unpayable
debt usually, saving someone's life the person
who invokes the law is demanding the benefit
of the target's unexpected luck.
This can be anything, but the trick is that
the item is bestowed by luck and fate, and
is unknown to the person giving the item away
until they return home safely.
"Find Geralt of Rivia.
He is your destiny."
Many parables involve the trope of a nobleman
traveling and having their life saved by someone
of lower birth.
Rather than accept the immediacy of gold or
other form of material wealth, the peasant
will invoke the Law of Surprise, which leads
to the nobleman having to give up something
far more precious.
When the nobleman grows selfish and attempts
to thwart this invocation of fate by either
trying to pay the peasant off or attempting
to kill them, terrible things befall them.
Tales using this trope are meant to highlight
the virtues of selflessness and humility good
people and kings honor their bargains, even
when the cost is exceedingly high, and the
universe should punish those who do not.
"The Law of Surprise has been called.
You kill them, you kill me."
Here's how the Law of Surprise comes into
play in the first season of The Witcher.
Many years before the events of the series,
Lord Urcheon, humble knight of the realm,
saves the king from death.
With extreme humility, Urcheon insists he
needs no material benefit for doing so, but
upon the king's continued pressure, chooses
the Law of Surprise as his repayment, never
once imagining it would mean Calanthe's unborn
child.
Having been cursed to look like a hedgehog
from a young age, he did his best to stave
off the fate the Law of Surprise demanded
until his curse lifted hearing the twelfth
peal of a bell in the course of his life.
Fate, of course, intervenes, and Urcheon meets
Princess Pavetta seemingly by chance, and
they fall in love.
Their secret betrothal is what drives him
to interrupt the Feast of Cintra, demanding
what is his by ancient right.
"Lioness of Cintra!
I come to claim what is rightfully mine!
Pavetta.
By the Law of Surprise."
Queen Calanthe gets mad, there's that big
fight, and Geralt steps in directly to save
Urcheon's life twice in succession.
When Calanthe finally relents, Urcheon insists
just as the king had done years before to
repay Geralt for his intervention.
Geralt, believing all this to be traditionalist
nonsense, chooses the Law of Surprise over
literally everyone else's interruption that
maybe, Geralt buddy, you should think it through.
Alas, he does not, and the cheeky revelation
of Pavetta vomiting immediately afterward
reveals her pregnancy.
Ciri is on the way, and Geralt refuses to
recognize what he has wrought for himself.
He mocks the concept of destiny openly over
his friend Mousesack's warnings, and leaves...
to his continued and countless future troubles.
It's only when he accepts his responsibility
under the Law of Surprise that he is put at
ease.
Geralt is sympathetic; he is a man of forced
circumstances, living a life he had no choice
in and basically waiting to die, though he
strives to at least be effective in his profession.
His scintilla of hope for something better
through Yennefer is lost precisely because
of the selfishness through which he employed
the Law of Surprise thinking he'd cheated
someone out of a child he could never bear
himself with no consequences, and when it
got tough, abandoning Ciri to a
much uglier fate than necessary.
Both Geralt and Calanthe thought destiny was
hogwash, tried to abuse others' belief in
it for their own ends, and ended up severely
punished for it.
"But you can't outrun destiny just because
you're terrified of it.
It's coming, Geralt.
Not believing won't change that."
The punishment is what engenders belief in
fate but too late for Calanthe, and almost
so for Geralt.
Ciri is consequential both because of the
potent magical bloodline she belongs to, as
well as her unknown attachment to Geralt through
what amounts to his own selfish stupidity.
It's much more than a simple bit of moral
instruction to the world of The Witcher: it's
magic making itself known in its world, and
the mortals within it are merely shifting
among its tides.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.